військові 127 окремої бригади тероборони
завдають удару по мінометному розрахунку
росіян які зайшли на українську
територію на Харківщині працює танк т-64
яким бригада забезпечила себе сама
трофейний танк
єсть трофейних працюємо так Що тут у нас
навчали як кажуть для кожного для
кожного танка танки одне з ключових
озброєнь у нинішній війні за оцінками
української сторони для звільнення
окупованих територій ЗСУ потрібно від
500 до 700 танків голова правління
німецького оборонного концерну
райнметаль Армін папергер вважає що
потреба навіть вища 600-800 танків для
перемоги над Росією за словами папергера
райнметаль веде перспективні переговори
з Києвом про будівництво заводу на
території України такий завод за 200 млн
доларів зможе виробляти до 400 нових
танків пантера на рік експерти називають
це позитивним сигналом для України під
час війни знаходяться компанії готові на
довгострокові інвестиції
думаю що на нинішньому етапі йдеться
скоріше про економічні причини звісно є
і військо політичні компоненти цієї
історії будівництво заводу має схвалити
уряд Німеччини Але зараз я бачу це так є
німецька фірма яка зацікавлена у
будівництві заводу в Україні це саме те
що потрібно Києву зокрема інвестори
готові будувати навіть під час війни та
йти на ризик тож це швидше економічний
сигнал
експерти наголошують райнметаль - це
комерційне підприємство орієнтоване на
отримання прибутку і нагадують до
анексії Криму компанії кілька років
будувала центр бойової підготовки в
нижньомуродській області Росії рішення
про будівництво заводу в Україні ще не
ухвалене як відзначає Експерт у питаннях
військово-промислового комплексу Сергій
згорець перед цим варто узгодити ще
низку питань Влас
виробниковому танків є
консорціум Краус Мафія вегема тобто
структура яка власне відповідає за
виготовлення танку в цілому аритмедл
відповідає за
башту і за нову гармату І власне ми
розуміємо що ініціатива арифметила
полягає в тому по розширити ринки збуту
для своєї продукції але коли ми говоримо
про завод то я думаю що треба знати і
позицію концерна Краус ман член комітету
з питань оборони німецького бундестагу
Нільс грюндер в інтерв'ю ДВ пояснив що
для будівництва заводу не потрібно буде
погодження з німецьким урядом Утім
дозвіл ФРН знадобиться для постачання
вже готових танків у тому числі Україні
водночас за словами депутата для самої
Німеччини плюс угоди в тому що в
довгостроковій перспективі не треба буде
чіпати запаси бундесверу Україну можна
буде озброювати танками виробленими в
Україні будівництво німецького заводу в
Україні ґрюндер підтримує із політичних
міркувань
незалежно від питання чи взагалі буде
побудований завод в Україні Німеччина
має брати на себе більше в питання
архітектури Безпеки Європи Німеччина має
лідерські амбіції в Європі їх треба
підкріпити діями це спрацює тільки Якщо
ми візьмемо на себе більшу
відповідальність за безпеку самих себе
та наших сусідів з ЄС в Німеччині треба
більше інвестувати у військову
інфраструктуру досягти нарешті рівня
військових витрат у 2% від ВВП водночас
постає питання безпеки майбутнього
підприємства хоча завод поки лише в
проєкті заступник голови Ради Безпеки РФ
Дмитро Медведєв уже пригрозив відзначити
початок його будівництва салютом із
калібрів у самому рай-металь певні що
українська ППО зможе захистити завод
експерти також Припускають що Можна було
б розмістити на заході України в горах
або під землею тоді як погрози Росії
фахівці не радять розцінювати як можливу
ескалацію
по-перше ми вже бачили постійні
негативні реакції Росія Надії заходу у
цій війні поки що вони лишаються на
словесному рівні тому я не думаю що й
історія із заводом призведе до ескалації
А по-друге чи треба взагалі брати це до
уваги у довгостроковій перспективі
йдеться про деескалацію чи навіть
закінчення війни тож Мені здається що ми
надто часто ставимо це питання про
можливу ескалацію з Росією
в Україну вже постачаються німецькі
леопарди щоправда з Польщі експерти
відзначають що невдовзі ЗСУ цілком
перейде з радянських на західні танки на
думку військового експерта Сергія згурця
завод райнметаль міг би стати дієвим
кроком у цьому напрямку експерт вважає
що ідеальний варіант для України якщо
райнметаль скооперується з українськими
розробниками зброї і не лише
виготовлятиме танки пантера які Поки
існують лише в демонстраційному
екземплярі а й ремонтуватиме вже
поставлені у країні леопарди однак за
словами Сергія згурця Україні усе це
обійдеться недешево зараз питання щодо
вартості робочої сили в яке раніше
вважалося
певною перевагою там України там чи
пострадянського простору воно вже не
працює зараз
питання вартості танків Скоріш є
інтегральний показником від вартості
комплектуючих які уже ну достатньо
суттєво зросли і значною мірою зараз
головний виклик що головним ресурсом є
не гроші зараз грошей для зброї в світі
є багато немає часу для її виготовлення
і обмежені потужності для її
виготовлення питання часу одне з
ключових якщо рішення про будівництво
танкового заводу буде ухвалене на його
спорудження можуть піти роки -
зазначають експерти турецька компанія
байкар понад рік тому заявила про плани
збудувати завод з виробництва Дронів
байрактар в Україні нині в компанії
зазначають на будівництво підприємства
піде до двох років а протягом минулого
року готувалася правова база водночас на
думку експерта Сергія згурця турецький
німецькі підприємці далеко не єдині хто
цікавиться Україною а серед світових
виробників зброї вже почалася боротьба
за український ринок
які надходять в українську армію від
закордонних виробників вони проходять
певний тест реальною війною і тому усі
виробники розуміють що це одна складова
того що треба щоб наша зброя була в
Україні а потім Україна буде повністю
переоснащувати свою армію тими зразками
які будуть найбільш оптимально підходити
до
нових викликів війни тому що якщо
Україна буде першим користувачем оцього
танку пантер 51 Київ 51 то фактично
потім я думаю що і сам бундесвер буде
закуповувати цей зразок розуміючи
наскільки ефективно він був в бойових
діях з реальною загрозою у вигляді
російської танкової армади не виключено
що поки нові оборонні підприємства
зокрема і танковий завод запрацюють в
Україні війна вже закінчиться але це не
означає що Україні не знадобиться зброя
для захисту